>>Khaldoon H. Tabaza: Hello, I'm Khaldoon
Tabaza and I'm the managing director of Riyada
Ventures.
So, I'm here in Davos and have attended some
of the _____ leaders program and today the
main program started and we had a session
about the Middle East.
And what I'd like to report is that, you know,
the view of basically the penniless what they
said has been extremely frustrating. We've
been hearing the same and the same issues
being discussed and been seeing the same people
talking about the same thing and talking in
terms of millions and hundreds of millions
of jobs that are required and hundreds of
billions of dollars that are invested by Middle
Eastern countries. And they need to invest
in education, and they need to invest in entrepreneurship
and they need to invest in job creation. But
we've seen very, very little practical steps.
So I don't know what happens when these people
go to their offices. I don't know why it's
so difficult to translate what they're talking
about into actionable small steps by governments
in the Middle East. Just extremely frustrating.
We can see countries and regions and nations
of much less natural resources doing much
more in terms of build up of their knowledge
economy, in terms of encouraging entrepreneurship,
in terms of encouraging innovation.
Up until now the hardest task in the other
world is to get somebody seed stage funding.
So somebody starting starting a new business
wanting to get some seed stage funding wanting
to go and build up a you know go and basically
get space in an incubator finds it very tough.
Let's get something done about this. And this
is me reporting from Davos. Thank you.